welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz today i'm
really excited to be joined by callum
buxton who is the client partner for hr
and people functions at habery
callum started his recruitment career at
bnc which is the professional service
arm of the edeca group in 2014
after working within the public sector
for eight years
over the seven years he was there callum
progressed from associate consultant to
senior consultant and was responsible
for building out a brand new division
within hr operations
as well as this callum got the
opportunity to be a shadow board
executive member which meant he was
tactically involved in helping direct
board level initiatives strategies and
projects at the edeka group
in august 2020 callum then joined habery
who are a well-established executive
search firm specialising within the life
sciences space where he now partners
with hr and people functions within life
sciences callum welcome to the podcast
how are you morning good afternoon i've
lost track of the time or all right
as you'll know we'd like to start with a
million pound question
so i'd love to hear your take on
what you believe are the characteristics
and traits that make up a a highly
successful high performing recruitment
consultant in in today's market
yeah sure so
um i think there's so many different
ideas about what success is um whether
that's billings or whether that's how
you build your relationships but the the
most important thing to me is a customer
focus
and i don't just mean clients by that
but it is
everything you do in search in
recruitment you're thinking about the
person you're speaking to and how you
add value to them how you make that
relationship work um and how you can
often become a trusted partner rather
than just a transactional supplier
that's a really critical thing i think
that everybody needs to develop is that
focus on their customers
the second bit is just a really strong
level of humanity and just being a
genuine person having a lot of
authenticity to who you are and what you
do
the the best search and recruit
professional i've ever seen are
those who are really comfortable being
themselves being very genuine being very
honest in how they build their
relationships
how they represent themselves
it it does and you know what it's
there's a being human one was something
it took me a while to to lock down my
early career me was
voicemails that sounded almost automated
and robotic my team actually joked i
could just be an auto dialer
pre-recorded like a ppi message um and
it wasn't until i started to be a bit
more myself a bit more natural
bringing you know connections to who i
am and how i feel personally to the
relationships the dynamics and stuff and
building those links let's talk about
that
the way i did very quickly because i
think people can really i think everyone
goes on that journey and i think
like i may you may or may not agree but
i i do really believe over the last 12
or so months and going into
2022
the amount of people that are in there
sort of naught to 12 18 months part of
their recruitment journey will be huge
just because of the amount of companies
that have been hiring to keep up with
their clients demands and most companies
that i speak to have really really got
back to hiring that trainee um
non-experienced
level person just because they've had
little or no success hiring experienced
people because let's be honest if if if
you if you're half decent you should be
making some good money uh right now
right with with the with all-time high
job markets and how busy it is so
so so why i think this is important is
that i i i can definitely relate to that
where you sort of got this like really
professional mask on
you're like so conscious of the other
person's opinion of you and you also as
you said you can sort of lose yourself
can't you and actually as you said
with time in hindsight clearly you
realize well actually when i actually
sort of was myself or i really owned who
i was and these things i actually built
bit better business relationships and
that impacted my performance so what was
it looking back what was it that held
you back what was it that that made you
that automated dialer pers like what
what was it do you think that held you
back that people maybe relate to and we
can talk a bit about how you broke
through that or what was the catalyst to
break from that
i i think the reason i i kept that
really professional mask when i started
was
a massive amount of professional
nervousness so i came into recruitment
with zero experience i've never done
recruitment and i've never done hr so
i knew nothing about my disciplined
vertical and i knew nothing about how to
actually be a good recruiter and what
that meant
one of the very first meetings i ever
went on the customer actually said to me
so why are you the partner i should have
you don't know anything about hr you've
never had an hr you don't know anything
about recruitment you've only been doing
this three months
so i
yeah that was that was really
challenging um it put me on the spot to
think a lot and what it then meant is i
had this idea in my head that you know i
had to act
like how i thought this professional
person should be
21 baby-faced completely green and i
just thought i've gotta act like i'm a
business professional i've gotta act
like i
um someone that you should be speaking
to because i'm you know i sound good or
i look good or i act good i was working
in
um an area where a number of my my
competitors were well established knew
their markets and obviously older and
more established than me so
i felt like i had to build this air of
being something bigger than i was i
think that's where i got that and then
okay love that
what so then what were some of the what
were some of the moments or things that
made you realize hang on a minute i've
i've been missing a bit of a trick here
like i don't know and like when did you
start to realize actually i need to
actually it's probably a better idea to
own who i am or bring more of myself to
the table like
it was looking at those around me who
were successful and seeing how they did
it and then i very quickly realized
yes i'm the youngest person in this room
yes i'm the least experienced person in
this room
but all the people around me are acting
natural they're not trying to be more
professional act older even though they
were
they were just being themselves um i was
really lucky that the person i was
learning recruitment research from you
know spent her in made her entire
business out of being emotionally
empathetic to her customers the business
development call for her was speaking
about you know the school run and
speaking about how difficult it is
trying to balance being a working mum
and i realized
you know having that level of
personality and being that individual
allows you to build such a stronger
connection you know you go from being
this
automated faceless brand image to being
a person yeah and ultimately that's
that's how the world works isn't it
people
buy from people not from brands not from
personas they buy from people and if you
are hiding who you are as that person
it's so much harder to build a
relationship of trust it's so much
harder to engage in a personal level so
i'm going to put you on the stop on the
spot column okay
so
i want to hear because people you know
what you said earlier around what you
experienced quite early on
i think i think people will be
experiencing that right now or will be
worried about being asked that question
and as i said a lot of people listening
a lot of people
uh in their recruitment career right now
be quite early on and may feel the
things that you're talking about
so
i want to let let's sort of put you in
that situation again
with hindsight of all the experience you
have now the benefit you have of that if
someone was to ask you that and you was
in the but you had the exact same
experience he was there a couple of
weeks months whatever
how would you answer that question when
i say callum
why would i why would i choose you you
know nothing about hr you know nothing
about our people function you've got no
experience like why why would i choose
you what how would you how would you
approach that
if i was
know what i know now but be in that
situation i would be a very genuine
person and show that level of
vulnerability i would i would admit that
you can't deny the fact that you lack
that experience but you can own that to
your own benefit so you can say yep i'm
i'm new i'm learning this is all new to
me
but then you can own the things that you
are doing so you can say i'm speaking to
people in this market day in day out it
may be new to it i may be new to it but
i'm very quickly becoming an expert in
this field and i spend my time day in
day out speaking to the experts in this
field um i also was you know
at that time still now able to to be
surrounded by a very strong team of
individuals so
you can borrow their credibility and say
again i'm new to this but i'm working in
a team that have got over 100 years
search experience
so
i am being partnered and being supported
and being grown and developed
constantly so
i think if you try and hide that lack of
experience if you try and get defensive
about that lack of experience people
will see through it straight away and i
think that's where that level of
authenticity that level of genuineness
that level of vulnerability comes in you
know you own the fact that
you don't have to experience it and be
very abrasive of it and ultimately
that's only going to be happening to you
once twice three times and that was
probably for me a massive learning curve
because it meant that in that first year
no question a customer gave me was worse
than that question you know i was able
to to come out of that meeting and
survive
so every other meeting was never as bad
as that one um
and
it's only a short period of time you
know you can very quickly learn what
you're doing very quickly become an
expert so
i'd say great i love it i think i just
love the fact you can i think that's the
great the really good advice there is
like
yeah i own it but own the bits that you
that you will be sort of um that you can
control and that you can do like you
said speaking to
every single person in the market i can
every single day but i love that like
just just owning that and that sort of
will immediately make them feel it make
them feel at ease or like you're just
taking that power away from them isn't
it when you're going you're completely
right i i don't have all the experience
but this is what i will be doing
um
yeah i love that i know that'll be
really helpful for people
so
loads we can unpack here right but what
i'm really keen to sort of dig into when
we spoke was just this journey of you
transitioning from bnc to then getting
into a sort of exact search environment
so now we're going to really dig into
that but just a couple of things i want
to touch on before we get there
firstly just i'm just curious
like from what i can see on your journey
you've clearly been a man man of the
people
[Laughter]
elected counsellor for uh
like your local area
like just interested like
where where would i don't know how
how was that draw i don't know where's
that drive but like where did that come
from where was that like how and then
how is it i don't know how how's that
journey then sort of cross-pollinated
with what you've ended up where you've
ended up taking your career out of
interest like one
where did that drive come from and and
what did you learn from it and two
how did how do you feel it then maybe
helped you in the quite quite
professional
environment in recruitment and building
your career there i'm just curious
yeah okay that's a really interesting
question um so i mean the whole time of
me coming into into politics being in a
public office came from the fact that i
have this really strong personal belief
that
it's the responsibility of every person
to make the world around them a better
place and you can do that in a really
small way by simple acts of kindness or
you can do that in big ways by service
by different things you do it and my way
to do that was to go
i i can make a difference i i have an
ability to speak in public i have an
ability to
win trust and support i have an ability
to think very critically and to make
change so let's let's do that let's
represent people let's take a collective
voice and make action from that
and i think
that guiding ethos of just constantly
thinking how can i
make things around me better guide
everything i do
so
you know i still do that in in work now
i'm constantly looking at how do we work
how do we do what we do better for
everyone around us whether you have
customers whether that's the community
whether it's the environment whether
that's our own process
just this constant thought of how where
did that come from better like as you
have got people in your family that have
got a similar mindset or because i mean
some people may say that but do they do
anything about it do they do they use
their recycling bin or do they do other
things maybe not
really um i honestly don't know it's
just this this mental idea that i've
always grown up with that
we're here not to we're here to enjoy
ourselves and to be the best but also to
make things constantly better you know i
love this idea that the next generation
that comes after me is going to have a
much better environment to work in
because of what we've done as discipline
as an industry as a world as a
generation and that our generations in
10 15 years time are going to be so much
better and you know if i reflect to the
way that our grandfathers were working
you know 50 years ago mining and culpits
i'm really thankful that
because they did that hard work to me
that we don't have to
and i don't have to be in that
environment now because the generations
before me made the world a better place
so i don't have to do that
that's what i want to do i want to make
the world for everyone i think that's
brilliant to me better so
you've got that mindset
how what what did you learn because you
obviously i'm from whenever i
i don't know whenever i learn or consume
in terms of politics and these types of
things
being in the constructs of like
the system and how things work like you
might have that mindset but i don't know
you may have ended up feeling
frustrations on things that you'd really
like to change but can't because of how
things work with these things i guess
just last question on it really like
what obviously you did it for four years
so like what what did you if you went
into it with that mindset what did you
learn
being in that environment or
being limited to what you can and can't
do in that construct of being an elected
counselor and the things you can do
yeah
i learned a significant amount of
patience and yeah yeah
patience is the biggest thing i got out
of that
yeah and and that you know that's
critical when you start thinking about
being in search and recruitment yeah
patience and resilience you know the
public sector allows things take five
times as long as they do it in any other
world but there's so much levels of
bureaucracy of process that you have to
go through you can't just have an idea
and make a change overnight it has to be
very slow it has to be very well thought
it has to be very calculated
um and it also has to be
um in the best interest that was
something i learned in constant as well
no matter what you do yeah someone's
going to be unhappy you know you can
have the best
means motivation idea in the world
someone's going to think you are the
worst person ever for doing that and so
it's developing that level of resilience
of no matter how good of something you
do
someone's not going to be happy and
whatever you do it's going to take a
long time change isn't imminent and it
also gave me a really strong
i suppose insight into critical thinking
about how decisions in general are made
so now when i think about the way i work
with my customers and my organizations i
try and put myself in that mindset of if
they're making a decision how is that
actually made if they're trying to make
a change process how is that actually
happening because
if you just kind of look at it from an
external perspective of i'm unhappy
about something i want something to be
different or i'm i'm happy and i want
something to change why isn't it
changing yet and you have a very
blinkered view externally about why
that's happening it can be really easy
to become frustrated
if you try and have that bigger picture
understanding of
i'm going from here and i need to get
here but what actually has to happen to
get there it makes you much more
welcoming of the time of the process of
the change of aware of what can go wrong
and i think that's how i've been able to
bring that into my professional career
is a really strong understanding that my
customers want to do something it can't
just happen they've got processes
approvals changes they have to go
through they've got stakeholders they've
got to keep happy and you've got to be
really aware of what process looks like
to make it happen and not just be really
blinking about what your personal
interest is on that from my next one i
love it i think um love that love that
mentality and
yeah i'm sure that that that was as you
said at times very difficult frustration
thinking why do i do this so no thanks
for sharing that so
look so b and c then you touched a bit
on some of the early challenges that you
you faced
um
i guess what i'm always interested to to
find out and ask a lot of people this so
always interested to hear people's take
but but most people listen to this they
will have aspirations to go from where
they are today
to become a principal senior director
that they want to progress their career
so i guess what i'm always keen to find
out is as you all know
recruitment is competitive internally
just as much as it is externally
so i guess what i wanted to find out
from you as you said you described a bit
your environment
typically the youngest in the room there
was a lot of experienced people around
you
what do you think
looking back at your time at bc what do
you think you did well
that enabled you to
push your your career forward if that
was getting to senior consultant if that
was getting the opportunity to be a
shadow executive board member like what
what was it that callum did well that
enabled you to
to push on your career to progress and
and get those opportunities that i'm
sure other people were going for and
trying to grab for themselves as well
okay
so i i was really lucky in my time at
dnc in that it was an
organization a team environment that
wanted you to succeed
every person
in in my team wanted everyone else to do
well in the team because everybody knew
that the one person doing well meant the
whole team did really well it wasn't a
shark environment where you have people
that are trying to stab you in the back
that were hiding translated trying to
steal customers trying to still be so
that was really great for me and what
that's instilled through me throughout
my career is that mentality of
me doing well means everyone else does
well but someone else doing well means
that everyone else which includes me
does well so i think that's how
i've been now take advantage of that as
i've grown through my career constantly
thinking
how can i do something that benefits
everyone around me but also benefits me
and then using that to my advantage when
there is an opportunity so
how can
other people winning business be
beneficial for me does that mean i can
win business on the back of that
does that mean there's opportunities for
me to grow
when i look at things like the shadow
executive role i did that was
very not focused on me as an individual
being a good person that was very
focused on how does an organization as a
whole get better
and the focus then was how do i feed
into that and that's where that came
from was
not thinking about me succeeding as an
individual not thinking about how can i
get a title or a status or how can i
progress my career but how can i do
something that makes things better for
everybody else and in turn success came
from that and that's
exactly the same as what i see here at
havery as well is how do we all think
individually
we want to achieve our group goal
when we all achieve that group goal
success then comes from me individually
off the back of that i get more business
i get more billings i get my promotions
i get my growth but it's constantly
thinking how do i
make everything better and interesting i
love that i found such a great mindset
and i think what i take from that is i'm
sure you've had that advice before where
like if you aspire to be a leader then
you need to be a leader before you are
one it's sort of what i take from that
is that your mentality was like right
yes i'm here for myself and like yes i
have my own goals
but i'm going to approach it as like as
you said like having the wider mindset
or the bigger picture of like how can i
ha what can i do that could benefit
everyone and have that mentality and in
turn
you've got the promotion opportunities
you've got opportunities to then
influence the things that did benefit
everyone which in turn benefited you
so um yeah i love that that's brilliant
so i guess the final thing on b c then
obviously spoke about
the the early meetings obviously he was
responsible for
basically building out that hr
operations piece so i guess the thing
that i'd love to just get your take on
looking back on that was what what were
some of the we can get sort of quite
practical here but as you were building
that out looking back what were some of
the the key things that you did
you think quite well that enabled you to
build traction
um in that market which as you said you
didn't have experience in you didn't
have the expertise and obviously
everyone listen uh again there will be
people that are now building a brand and
building expertise in a new market and
hoping
to build that a successful expertise and
build a desk and these things so looking
back what were some of the one to two
three things you think you did really
well that enables to build traction
in that operations and then we'll get on
to um hey
yeah so building h operations is really
nervous for me because when i first
joined um bnc the the basic message was
we do not do operational hiring we only
do mid-senior management we do not do
anything entry level junior and then
halfway into my career we went hey this
is now all you're going to do you have
to make this market that for the last
three you know two three years you've
told your customers we don't even touch
all that business you've turned away
you've now got to go wherever
so i think that the main thing there was
we were semi-fortunate is that the
people i then spent two or three years
building relationships with as
candidates became my customers
so i was able to use those relationships
in a different way so everyone that i've
been speaking to about their own
personal career suddenly became my
hiring managers and
we were able to roll that out from there
i think what was critical in that
happening was that always on mentality
was not separating
clients and candidates into these two
separate rules but just seeing everybody
externally as a customer because if i
had only ever focused on those
individuals as candidates when you then
need to say hey you're now a hiring
manager for me
and you treated it differently it would
have worked the fact that throughout
that time it was always focused on how
do you get the best experience for me as
a customer
meant that when it was now time to speak
them as a hiring manager it was a really
smooth transition because they were able
to go you're interested in being as
a person as a customer someone who has
experience with you rather than just
someone you're going to play and never
speak to
with that along with any kind of build
up there's always needs to be a massive
amount of patience you may see one or
two quick wins but it's such a slow
build whenever you're trying to build
something new if you're going to do it
in a really thoughtful way so the focus
there was also on and and every time now
as well sorry when i'm doing the build
at havery was
how do i build a long-term relationship
how do i make relationships now that are
still going to be working for me in one
three five years not just how can i
quickly win business and make placements
and i think they're the two really
critical things
but for any kind of build out is the
patience to do it right and think of
those long term relationships and to
have that always on customer focused
mentality that everyone you speak to is
going to be a customer for you in some
capacity i love that tip so much i think
just i think sometimes people
people really struggle with that
um and i do think sometimes it's
it's um at the detriment of like
the typical journey that recruiters go
on because most people
most companies have people start on like
the candidate side and then they're like
right okay now start speaking to clients
so it can be quite easy to go
okay i'm just doing i'm just doing
candidates just doing candidates and i
was like oh i've got to do clients and
it can be quite easy to view those
different things and i i definitely did
that
but the um the chap um nick carmen who
who he just believes this is the big
reason as to why he's been able to
really build out a successful career for
himself and he sees again a lot of
people
fall short of this and i definitely see
this in the l d conversations i have
that you can sort of have your blinkers
on
um and you and you miss those sort of um
commercial opportunities
to go oh callum you know you mentioned
about your hiring manager doing this
tell me more about that rather than
just sticking to i'm speaking to callum
as a candidate he's telling me the
reasons for leaving did you get what i'm
in so it's like did you have you always
had that where did that come from i
think i think that's important to
understand why why that's in why that's
critical because i think a lot of people
fall short on that
when i i first started purely in the
candidate role for the first 18 months
of my career was pure candidate
generation wow sourcing screening
building relationships and then passing
that on to
the consultant that i work with to go
hey these are the people that are right
for your jobs
and i think something was instilled for
me from day one is always thinking
bigger picture yeah if you're speaking
to a candidate now don't just think
about
hello candidate are you suitable for
this one particular search that i'm
running or are you suitable for this one
particular job but think bigger how is
this candidate suitable for me
as a specialist in my market so i was
always trying to think okay yes i'm
looking for an hr business partner right
now to work for ex-company
but also i need hr business partners in
my network so i was always trying to
think bigger of are you suitable for
this but also are you suitable more
generally in a wider scope so then when
it came to that extension of okay i now
need to start incorporating client
conversations into this it was just an
extension of that of how are you someone
that should be within my network
so if you have a very blinkered view on
um i am focused on one particular thing
right now
it makes it really hard i think you
always have to have that slightly more
open perspective whatever you do so if
it's candidate delivery not just
thinking what do i need for this search
but what do i need for my network
holistically if you're in a 360 role not
just thinking
who do i need to make a job with right
now who's my focus for business
development but thinking on a wide scope
of who are good customers who are good
clients for me to have in my network i
should be building relationships with so
always trying to be non-blinkered in
your approach love that hopefully
yeah that's brilliant i think i think
that's and i think just some final note
on that because i speak to recruit
learners all day like if you have that
mindset and you're listening to this if
you have that mindset you might be the
delivery role right now might be early
on but if you have that mindset and your
manager the business you work for
like see you having that more
non-blinking view
bigger picture thinking they're going to
get excited and that's what they want to
see from you as well do you know what i
mean um so i think also in terms of
progress in your career and and doing
the right things and showing the right
things you're managing these types of
things i think that also go down
really well because i know business
owners and leaders can get quite
frustrated when
they find out certain information with
what you shared with them and you then
and then they go why didn't you ask them
this or that was a great opportunity to
do that right so i think really
cultivating that non-blinkered approach
will really help so i love that so
let let some plat then um as the the
second part there's hebrew so what just
to frame this up
so firstly what i'd love to just hear
your take on was what was your
perception of executive search
before you joined hayberry
how would you describe it
my perception of executive search before
i started doing it was probably very
similar to everyone else's perception of
executive searches yeah normal search
process that you get paid up from it's
requested and and that's really
interesting because now that i do
executive search in in its truest form
everyone i speak to when they think
about it that's what they think of they
think it's a standard recruitment
process
but you do it on a retained basis and
that was my perspective before i started
doing it and
again that was maybe a little bit
blinking of me to not be aware of what
that meant
yeah
okay
so
let's let's break this down and there's
a number of things i want to break down
which i know people would be interested
in
so i guess firstly what what has what
has surprised you most
about now being in an executive search
environment for the last
year and a half
um we obviously went into it that
mindset that perception so now what do
you think is what has surprised you most
around working in in this way and in
that environment
how similar they still are so
regardless of the fact whether you're
speaking to an 18k hr administrator or
an hr
a chief hr officer that's going to be on
a 500k package
that the process is the fundamentals of
what you do throughout search are the
same um
but the destruction to it is very very
different
the structure
yeah and
and i suppose the process the the level
of detail the level of support the level
of guidance you have to go into that's
probably a massive change that's the
biggest thing i see when now i'm in
exact search looking at what we do so
the support and guidance we give to our
customers the support and guidance we
give to our candidates our clients
throughout all the process but the level
of detail you go into um
you know the level of screening the
level of sourcing level searching
i think
everybody knows this term head hunting
you know everyone thinks that head
hunting is you go out and i've found
someone like this i've head hunted them
when you think of except search it is
true head hunting it is
targeting specific people because of
their skill sets
rather than targeting anyone for a
generic skill set or it is a truly
extensive market search so the services
i run now
aren't just a matter of going okay my
customers told me they want this so i'm
going to try and find someone in their
immediate area that matches that and if
i can't find it it's not a problem
my job now is to find them that person
whether i find that in their local area
whether i find that domestically whether
i find that internationally whether i
have to find them alternatives it's it's
that massive focus on how do i fulfill
my customers need
and i don't have the ability to not do
that you know when i agree a mandate i
am committing to fill that that's why in
the last 18 months it's 100 success rate
for me because it's yeah that yeah and
that was a big shift as well going from
uh you know 40 to 60 percent success
rate to around 100 success rate because
you are did you do was it just
contingent that you did before yeah at
bnc very very heavily in in a contingent
world um you know or exclusive
contingent so it was paid upon yeah it
was on that exclusive supply basis
but when you then go into that much
greater level of extensive search to
committing to that is
is really mentally challenging but it's
so much more rewarding because i now go
into a search with this
mindset of i am partnering on the search
i am going to fill this
i will do everything i have to do to
find this person i will make sure every
single stone i have to turn is
i will look is every little looking
cranny to make sure i find this talent
because i i have to that's that's my
service offering
yeah so let let i wanna i'm keen to sort
of just just zooming on the mindset
piece because when i when i say for
example i sat down i caught up with
someone the other day and was talking
about how their years been and these
types of things and i i don't know if
you agree but obviously you're quite
active
on linkedin but i would definitely say
that this year over the last 12 18
months
like they're definitely more people
talking about retained
um and sort of
just
not not saying contingent is is rubbish
but i don't know i do feel like
sometimes people give off that
impression
right like why would you why would you
work continuing these things but i was
catching up with someone uh the other
day and i'm saying oh how's your year
been blah blah blah they're saying yeah
it's been great and i was out of
interest like have you sort of developed
any different solutions or we sold
different recruitment solutions and
they're like you know what we actually
haven't like every single deal that
we've done has been contingent
um and when i said oh that's interesting
like why haven't you explored
doing exec search retained whatever you
want to call it and typically and i i
would say this is typical is like
just that mindset of well
this is working why would i put my neck
on the line for it to potentially fail
and for it to not work right so this is
what i want to zoom on quickly you said
it was mentally challenging you come
from an environment whereas 46 success
rate so why would you not then go into
hebrew and go oh okay well i've now got
to have the mindset of no i am going to
deliver whereas before you would have
obviously said yeah i'll definitely help
you with this but you know that you you
may not be able to
to get the person they need so how do
you how do you deal with that and i
guess advice for people that
may find themselves interested or
curious around the retain piece or
getting paid up front or the whatever
you want to call it but have that mental
block or challenge of like what if i
fail what if i don't get this person
what if i don't deliver because i'm sure
that's something you had to deal with
yeah um
so if i knew what i knew now and took
that back two three years ago when i was
working in a heavily contingent market
i would have the mindset i have now
of
okay like do not fail you cannot fail
that is not an option and and
that's a bit of a contradiction on a
personal mantra i have which is failure
is okay but when you actually look at
the search go into that mindset of
not you can't fail but you you just will
succeed you have to succeed because that
is the option for you is is is winning
um if i was more reflective now i would
probably have turned away a lot of the
contingent business
when i was working at the market that i
knew i wasn't going to film i used to
work so many roles that i knew i wasn't
going to feel because i thought i just
had to so i was working on roles that
had six seven eight other agencies
partnering on them i was working on
roles that i just knew
the the talent for what that customer
wanted wasn't available or there was
unreal expectations or the market just
didn't allow it so if i was still
working in a highly contingent role or
highly contingent basis it would be that
focus on
let's win the business that i can feel
let's focus on that let's make sure i'm
filling roles and i'd focus on how i can
increase my success rate over how i
increase my volume of opportunity
and
i think that's that's probably the
biggest thing i've learned if i was to
go back to that now is treat it like
not failure isn't an option but success
is the only option you have to find this
talent that makes sense
yeah so what i really take from this
when i speak to people about this is
what i really take from it is
what you're actually saying and what you
now do is you work with like way more
committed clients
not just find that not that they may
financially commit that right we're
going to partner with you callum we're
going to start this mandate start the
search but just in the sense of like you
probably feel like success
will happen because
the client the customer is willing to
spend 45 minutes with you to really
paint a picture of
this is what we're looking for these are
the non-negotiables this is what we can
be flexible with these are the types of
companies that we've had success
do you get what i mean and i i think it
really comes down to like you just said
you were working on job because you felt
like you did but i'm sure also if you
were to call those customers up and go
hey look this is where i'm at with my
search at the moment i'm not quite sure
this skill set actually exists or this
experience happened like are you happy
to give me 20 30 minutes so we can talk
a bit about it further go column look i
haven't got time to do this like we've
got four or five other agencies send us
some cbs like crack on
so i really think comes down to the
client commitment piece where you feel
way more comfortable
with being more successful because you
know that one the clients the customer's
going to listen to you
like when you're going through your
search and you go actually after looking
at the market
i'm not i think we may have to look at
this or look at that instead and they're
going to be more willing to listen i
don't know that that's what i think
that's much more around the customer yes
it's not just our reminder of what we're
doing but it's how we work with those
customers so when we're accessing
business opportunities now that's part
of what we look at is this customer
actually committed to working with us is
this a customer that wants this to be a
true partnership so
we don't want to do transactional search
recruitment when i say transactional i
don't mean the level i mean the service
agreement we don't just want to be an
external supplier they go
here's a job go away and find someone
like you said it's that commitment for
the customer to go
i'm going to give you 45 minutes of my
time to talk about what i want in detail
to talk about
what
you are actually looking for and to be a
true partner so the way i work now is
yeah massively is an extension of a
search and hiring process it's not as an
excel supplier it is as an addition to
their process
and i think when you get that customer
commitment when you get that customer
that says
i want you to be an extension of us
you know with you're taking my brand
message you're being the representative
of my company that's where the success
comes from that's when you can then
bring that mindset up okay i have to
fill this i'll find a solution i'll find
talent when you're in that environment
where
you're just seen as a transactional
supplier by your customers i found it
really demoralizing it wasn't the
business i wanted to do it was the
business i knew i wasn't going to
succeed in so
focusing on
getting that level of commitment from
your customers
positioning yourself as a trusted
partner rather than just a supplier as
well i think it's critical
so i have to ask you
i'm sure most people
uh would agree and saying like a really
common sentence you may hear recruiters
say right now is it's a candidate driven
market there aren't enough candidates
these sorts of things so i have to just
get your perspective on this because i'm
sure it's something that you you're
continuing to find get better at what
from your perspective i know there's
nuances here what does a good
head-hunting approach look like
in your view let's say i know there's a
few different channels here but what
would you what would you say is the most
typical
i don't know like are you typically sort
of approaching people on the phone i
know there's a nuance here right it
depends but like i don't know there's it
people would like it it may be different
to
the phone approach compared to um in
mail or i don't know you tell me but
like what does good headlining look like
for you it varies by you know by the way
i do it i have successful as i do it the
way my colleagues took it will be very
very different i think
the challenge i have to went on right
now that says when they talk about the
candidate market yes it's the candidate
driven market
um no
there are i think it's wrong when people
say that there are not enough candidates
in the market i think there are ample
numbers numbers of professionals in
every discipline to find the roles
you're looking for and in some cases
that there might be scarce but
they're there yeah yeah i think what's
more important is it's a candidate
engagement market and that's the
critical part on any headline
is
now focusing on what the candidate wants
not what you want so whether you are
making that contact that headphone that
engagement over the phone through email
through
linkedin through carrier pidgins however
you're trying to get hold of that person
it's focused on them as a candidate
because you need to get more engaged
candidates not have a higher volume of
candidates and so that's something i try
and bring into
every outreach we possibly do and we're
trying to get customers focused on why
they should want to speak with us why
they should want to have a conversation
why this is an opportunity they should
be interested in and why it's exciting
for them
and not focus on
what i'm looking for what i want what i
need from this conversation yeah and
when you have that shift that's when you
start to get the more engaged candidates
that's when you can take that candidate
driven market that know what they want
that are
massively being con contacted by
hundreds of recruiters day in day out
and make your message showing through is
the one that's interesting to them
because they're engaged they're
attracted they're interested and you're
moving forward on that basis
let's just talk about this for a bit i
know this will be helpful for people
um so as you said i think how
what we want to avoid
not good practice i completely agree is
as you said
i end up in on callum's phone inbox
wherever it may be
and i'm spending most of my time going
hey callum i need you to have this skill
set i needed to do this i need to have
that experience i need you to this i i i
right
so could you just just unpack up just a
bit more on like when you say
it's like why they should be excited
about it it's about them like what does
that actually look like in context so i
don't know are you mentioning around
so you're in the leadership position
right now typically people like you want
to get to c-suite so this is why this
might be a bit i don't know like just
gives a bit more context because i think
that would be helpful for people
i'm guilty of still doing that you know
it still slips in i sent out the message
that can do this or i'm looking for this
um so i'm not gonna say i don't do that
because i still do and it does slip in i
think the focus is trying to pay
attention to what your market is looking
for and using that as the way of
engaging
so
yeah if i think about the markets i
approach in in human resources and
talents and people functions something
that's really attractive is growth so if
i was hiring a ta leader right now what
i wouldn't be saying is i have someone
that can do this
i would be presenting that opportunity
of saying um
here's an opportunity for you to do this
here's an opportunity for you to have
growth here's an opportunity for you to
achieve that thing you want right so
focusing on
that external mindset thinking if i was
this candidate what would i want to
receive what do i want to see what do i
want to grow
yeah and then giving them that as the
message
rather than
what do i need to demonstrate
we'll try and pull that as well into
the way i advertise so
now it's not
i'm looking for someone that can do this
and you must have this as an ability it
is
this opportunity requires someone that
can achieve this and this
here's what you might need to do to
succeed in that but again it's focused
on that individual and how that links to
them rather than me and what i want from
them
yeah now thanks for sharing that
so
as as you come to the end here
um
i guess what what i'd be keen to to just
uh understand a bit more i'll get or
just just ask you i guess like
what obviously you've been obviously
moved to haberian sort of covered vibes
um
i guess what's
what what's what's sort of exciting in
hebrews world going into next year
um i have interest massive ongoing
growth we're looking at doubling our fte
um
three of the people in our team have
just moved into their first people
manager roles so that's really exciting
um and seeing that ongoing growth that
we have for our team we are constantly
trying to look at how
can we do more for our customers how can
we grow how can we offer more solutions
that's the really exciting things for
next year um we're also thinking about i
think this is the case for a lot of
people but how do we evolve how do we
have
the processes we're going to need in
2025 yeah and how is that us now rather
than how do we have the processes from
before so just a massive time of change
transformation excitement and lots of
new future opportunities for us to
succeed and do well
i love that and look craig if i'm wrong
here but i know when we spoke before
that
something that um
there's like you uh hey there's a real
sort of solid amount of um women in in
the leadership team right
i've got that right yeah okay so i'm
just i'm just always curious i think um
what i'd love to just hear your
perspective and i don't know exactly
what
the b and c make up what uh b and c
makeup was but like how how do you feel
from your perspective how do you feel
having like a really strong woman
leadership team in in a recruitment
environment which isn't typically the
case
impacts culture impacts
the way that you do business just
curious like personally i think there'll
be
just a ton of benefit personally but i
don't know just just interested to hear
your take from me
i know recruitment typically think of it
it's it's a male heavy industry but i've
never been in that environment when i
worked at bnc i was um on my team doing
hr i was one of
uh four and i was the only guy that was
always in that environment where i was
surrounded
by gender balance here at havery you
know as you and i spoken about before um
a large amount of our leadership team is
is female when i first started in hebrew
i think i was like
one of four guys in a team of
30. um
and i think alongside that is a broader
range of diversity when you look at
nationalities when you look at
orientation when you look at interests
i think when you have diversity in
recruitment it can only be a good thing
because you remove you know all the
things everyone's trying to remove at
the moment gets rid of any affinity and
unconscious bias it
allows a diversity of thought it allows
an inclusive mindset to happen because
if you've got a room that's an echo
chamber you've got 10 people that are
exactly the same demographic exactly the
same mindset you're always going to go
in one direction if you're an
environment that has a completely
diverse makeup both physically and
mentally you're going to be
constantly trying to think about things
differently and how does that scope and
that can only have a positive
manifestation so
um i'm quite lucky and i've always been
an environment that enables and
encourages diversity throughout my
entire career um
if organizations don't do that i think
they're massively missing uh
missing something they should be doing
to be better
absolutely
well look i know there's loads more that
we could go into but i've um really
enjoyed that conversation so many great
insights
for people excited to just obviously
always enjoy seeing your content on
linkedin and and uh yeah i think you've
been on a great journey from yeah being
a local councillor to
now uh yeah really building out yourself
for successful criminal recruitment so
thank you so much for coming on the
podcast sharing everything that you've
learned so far
thank you everything i see coming out of
our equipment mentors too i love the
community you're trying to build right
now that's you know one final piece of
information i'd say for anyone
recruitment never see people in
recruitment as competitors always see
them as industry peers and i love that's
what you're doing right now is building
this community of people where we can
all learn from each other
no worries
absolutely love it thanks a lot helen